GENERAL MARK HERTLING THERE.
AND SAM KYLIE, APPRECIATE YOU
TAKING TIME TO SPEAK WITH US.
>>> NOW THAT THE WAR HAS ENDED,
THE INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY
FACES A TOUGH QUESTION.
HOW TO WORK WITH THE TALIBAN
GOVERNMENT?
FOR THEIR PART, THE TALIBAN SAID
THEY WANT TO FORGE FAR-REACHING
INTERNATIONAL TIES.
THE GROUP SPOKESMAN, THROUGH
CHINA LINKS WITH CHINA, ARE A
KEY PRIORITY.
THEY ALSO HAVE EXISTING TIES
WITH TEAMS IN THE REGION.
WE TOLD YOU ABOUT THE QATARI
TEAM.
THE TALIBAN HAVE MAINTAINED A
POLITICAL OFFICE IN QATAR,
LEAVING THAT COUNTRY UNIQUELY
POSITIONED TO NEGOTIATE WITH
AFGHANISTAN'S NEW LEADERS.
I'M JOINED BY ASSISTANT FOREIGN
MINISTER OF QATAR AND LIVE FOR
US IN DOHA AT THIS HOUR.
MINISTER, THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR TAKING THE TIME TO SPEAK TO
US ON THE SHOW.
AS YOU HEARD ME SAY, WE'RE
LEARNING THAT A TEAM OF QATARI
TECHNICAL EXPERTS ARE IN KABUL
AT THE TALIBAN'S REQUEST.
WHAT IS THE TALIBAN ASKING OF
QATAR, REQUESTING HELP RIGHT NOW
FROM QATAR WITH?
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH, ISA.
ACTUALLY IT'S BEEN ALSO UPON THE
REQUEST OF OUR INTERNATIONAL
PARTNERS THAT WE WORK WITH THE
POWER THERE ON THE GROUND IN
AFGHANISTAN TO RESUME THE
AIRPORT SO THAT THE OUTBOUND
FLIGHTS AS WELL AS THE INBOUND
FLIGHTS CAN RESUME NORMAL
OPERATIONS.
AS YOU CAN IMAGINE, AFTER MANY
EXPERTS HAVE LEFT THE COUNTRY
AND AFTER THE OPERATORS AND MANY
OF THEM HAVE BEEN FOREIGNER
COMPANIES BASICALLY AND EXPERTS
HAVE FLED THE COUNTRY, TALIBAN
IS LEFT WITH VERY LITTLE
EXPERTISE TO RUN THE AIRPORT.
THAT'S ONE ASPECT OF IT.
THE OTHER ASPECT IS ACTUALLY THE
ACTUAL INFRASTRUCTURE.
IT SEEMS LIKE MANY OF THE
EQUIPMENT IS DAMAGED OR ACTUALLY
WAS TAKEN.
AND OF COURSE THERE IS A BLAME
GAME THERE BETWEEN THE DIFFERENT
PARTIES ON THE GROUND WHO HASN'T
DONE THIS OR THAT.
OUR ROLE HERE, OUR TECHNICAL
TEAM THERE, IS BASICALLY TO
FACILITATE, WORK WITH THE
INTERNATIONAL PARTNERS TO RESUME
THE OPERATIONS IN THE AIRPORT.
>> AND SO, MINISTER, DO YOU KNOW
AT THIS STAGE WHETHER QATAR
WOULD BE PROVIDING SECURITY AND
AIRPORT OPERATION?
AND IF SO, FOR HOW LONG?
>> WELL, NOT SECURITY.
AND THIS REMAINS A DEBATED
TOPIC.
IT SEEMS LIKE TALIBAN IS
INSISTING ON THE SECURITY
ASPECT.
YET WHAT THEY DON'T REALIZE IS
SECURITY IN AN AIRPORT IS VERY
DIFFERENT FROM SECURING THE
SURROUNDING SIDE OF THE AIRPORT.
SO, THEY DON'T REALIZE THINGS
LIKE BIOMETRICS AND ALL THE
MEASURES THAT ANY INTERNATIONAL
AIRPORT HAS TO HAVE IN ORDER TO
OPERATE.
SO, WE'RE TRYING TO NEGOTIATE
THIS, TO EXPLAIN THE COMPLEXITY
OF THE PROCESS.
BUT THE SECURITY IS DEFINITELY
AN ELEMENT THAT WILL NOT BE WITH
US ON QATAR.
AND WE'RE DISCUSSING THIS WITH
TALIBAN AND THE INTERNATIONAL
PARTNERS.
OUR PART WOULD BE THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AS WELL AS EVENTUALLY
HELPING WITH THE AIRCRAFT AS
WELL.
>> NOW, QATAR HAS BEEN PLAYING A
KEY ROLE, A CORRESPONDENT IS
SAYING IN DOHA IN TERMS OF THE
COMMUNICATION FRONT WITH THE
TALIBAN.
WHY DO YOU FEEL, MINISTER, THAT
THIS IS IMPORTANT RIGHT NOW?
>> WELL, IT'S EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THERE NEEDS TO
BE A CONSTRUCTIVE ENGAGEMENT.
I MEAN, ISA, IN THE G7 MEETING
THAT HAPPENED ONLY A COUPLE OF
DAYS AGO, WHICH QATAR, TURKEY,
THE NATO AND EU ALSO JOINED,
THERE WAS AN AGREEMENT THAT
THERE NEEDS TO BE CONSTRUCTIVE
ENGAGEMENT WITH TALIBAN SIMPLY
BECAUSE THEY ARE THE DEFACTO
AUTHORITY THERE RIGHT NOW.
NOW, IN TERMS OF OUR ROLE IN
MEDIATING AND ALSO FACILITATING
THOSE DISCUSSIONS BETWEEN
TALIBAN AND THE INTERNATIONAL
PARTNERS, YOU MIGHT HAVE HEARD
THAT MANY OF THE EU MISSIONS AS
WELL AS THE UNITED STATES
MISSION, DIPLOMATIC MISSION,
JAPAN'S, ALSO SOUTH KOREA'S
MISSION WILL ALL RELOCATE TO
DOHA.
SO, THIS WILL BE A CHANCE TO
FACILITATE A REAL DISCUSSION
AROUND THE CONTESTED ISSUES AS
WELL AS FACILITATING ALL THE
OTHER OPERATIONS FOR THE
CITIZENS OF THOSE COUNTRIES AS
WELL AS AFGHAN CITIZENS WHO
WOULD -- OR MIGHT END UP
EVACUATING TO THOSE COUNTRIES.
>> DO YOU WORRY -- I KNOW YOU'RE
TALK ABOUT CONSTRUCTING
ENGAGEMENT, THE IMPORTANCE OF
CONSTRUCTING ENGAGEMENT WITH THE
TALIBAN AT THIS STAGE, MINISTER.
BUT DO YOU WORRY -- FIRST OF ALL
DO YOU TRUST THE TALIBAN AND THE
PROMISES BEING MADE?
AND DO YOU WORRY, FRANKLY, THAT
IT COULD BACKFIRE?
>> WELL, WE HAVE OUR OWN WORRIES
AND CONCERNS, NO QUESTION ABOUT
THAT.
THIS NEEDS TO BE A TRUST
BUILDING PROCESS.
WE ALL AGREED WITH OUR
INTERNATIONAL PARTNERS THAT
RUSHING INTO RECOGNITION IS NOT
NECESSARILY THE WISEST DECISION
TO MAKE NOW, YET A CONSTRUCTIVE
DIALOGUE IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT.
SO, IT WILL BE A TRUST BUILDING
PROCESS.
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT, ISA, THAT
ALL OF US COLLECTIVELY BUILD AND
CAPITALIZE ON THE PRAGMATISM
THAT TALIBAN HAS SHOWN SO FAR.
TALIBAN NEEDS THE INTERNATIONAL
COMMUNITY.
THEY REALIZE THIS.
THEY SAY THIS.
AND THAT'S WHY WE NEED TO
CAPITALIZE ON THIS MOMENT.
SHUTTING THEM DOWN COMPLETELY IS
NOT GOING TO BE VERY HELPFUL IN
THIS SITUATION.
THAT'S WHY WE NEED TO THINK OF
OTHER WAYS TO ENGAGE WITH THEM
WITHOUT UNDERMINING HUMAN
RIGHTS, WITHOUT UNDERMINING
WOMEN'S RIGHTS, WITHOUT
UNDERMINING ALL THE
INTERNATIONAL STANDARDS THAT WE
ALL COLLECTIVELY EMBRACE.
AND WE THINK THAT THERE IS A
REAL OPPORTUNITY HERE TO
RATIONALIZE THE PUBLIC ACTIONS.
CHANGING THEIR IDEOLOGY MIGHT
TAKE YEARS AND DECADES IF IT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN ALTOGETHER.
YET RATIONALIZING THEIR PUBLIC
ACTIONS SHOULD BE OUR VERY CLEAR
AND PRAGMATIC AIM.
WE DON'T CARE AND WE SHOULDN'T
CARE ABOUT THEIR PRIVATE ACTIONS
WITHIN THEIR OWN PRIVATE
SPHERES.
WHAT SHOULD MATTER IS THE PUBLIC
SPHERE.
WHAT SHOULD MATTER IS THEIR
PUBLIC ACTIONS.
WHAT SHOULD MATTER IS THE
COLLECTIVE GOOD AND INTERESTS OF
THE PEOPLE OF AFGHANISTAN.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, ISA, AND
I WILL CONCLUDE WITH THIS POINT.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, WE SHOULD
NOT BE FOCUSING ON THE ELITISTS
AND THE AFGHAN SOCIETY.
WE SHOULD BE WIDER SOCIETY,
RURAL AREAS, OTHER PROVINCES.
THOSE PEOPLE WILL EVENTUALLY
SUFFER ECONOMICALLY UNLESS WE
JUMP IN AS THE INTERNATIONAL
COMMUNITY AND HELP.
AND THIS, UNFORTUNATELY, CANNOT
HAPPEN WITHOUT ENGAGING WITH ALL
PARTIES ON THE GROUND.
AND WE'VE BEEN FISHING FOR AN
INCLUSIVE GOVERNMENT FOR THE
TALIBAN IN OUR PAST DISCUSSIONS
AND STILL UNTIL THIS VERY
MOMENT, WE'VE BEEN PUSHING FOR
MORE WOMEN PARTICIPATION.
WE'VE BEEN PUSHING FOR WOMEN
EDUCATION.
AT THE END OF THE DAY THERE ARE
MANY MUSLIM COUNTRIES WHO ARE
ENGAGING IN DISCUSSIONS WITH
THEM, INCLUDING QATAR.
AND WE HAVE WOMEN EDUCATION.
WE HAVE WOMEN PARTICIPATING IN
THE WORK FORCE.
MORE THAN 50% OF OUR WORK FORCE
ARE WOMEN.
ALL THOSE POINTS WE TRY TO PUSH
IN OUR DISCUSSIONS WITH TALIBAN.
ONCE AGAIN, I WANT TO EMPHASIZE
WHAT MATTERS IS THEIR PUBLIC
ACTIONS.
AND THEY SHOWED A GREAT DEAL OF
PRAGMATISM THAT WE AS THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY SHOULD
CAPITALIZE ON.
>> SO, SO FAR YOU'RE SEEING A
GREAT DEAL OF PRAGMATISM.
NOT SURE WHETHER YOU'RE SEEING
ANY EVIDENCE YET OF A GENTLER,
MORE INCLUSIVE TALIBAN.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU'VE SEEN
THAT.
YOU CAN GIVE US AN IDEA IF
YOU'VE SEEN THAT, YOU'VE HEARD
THAT FROM THEM.
BUT I'M ALSO LOOKING TO KNOW,
MINISTER, WHAT IS THE RED LINE
FOR QATAR?
OF COURSE WE'RE HEARING ALL
THESE PROMISES FROM THE TALIBAN.
BUT WHERE DOES QATAR DRAW THE
LINE?
YOU MENTIONED HUMAN RIGHTS.
YOU MENTIONED WOMEN'S ISSUES AS
WELL, WOMEN INTEGRATION IN
SOCIETY.
WHERE DO YOU DRAW THAT LINE?
>> WELL, THERE IS A RED LINE
DEFINITELY.
BUT HUMAN RIGHTS AND WOMEN'S
RIGHTS IS ALSO A SPECTRUM.
NOW, WHAT WE HAVE SAID AND
COMMUNICATED VERY CLEARLY THAT A
RECOGNITION EVEN FROM THE SIDE
OF QATAR WILL ONLY COME IF THERE
IS AN INCLUSIVE GOVERNMENT.
AND THIS WILL BE THE FIRST
GE